cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us now david good morning
good morning
so pfizer has asked the fda to consider
boosters for all adults based on the
available data is that warranted
i think no question about it
unfortunately immunity wanes every month
you get the vaccine so by the time
you're at six months you're almost at
half the immunity that you were when you
were at your peak and what we know with
delta variant is you need a very high
level of immunity for protection so
we're going to need a booster and it's
because the virus has changed because we
have to be able to fight delta and i
think that's going to be critical and
obviously some steps states are going
forward and doing it on their own i
think you're going to see some changes
at the federal government level in the
next week or so
dr uh triple a's estimating that
thanksgiving travel this year will
return to near
pre-pandemic levels what are you
expecting and do you think people should
travel comfortably over thanksgiving and
christmas this year
i expect traffic jams um no seriously i
i think that we are getting a little bit
of covet fatigue
and all of us are letting down our guard
we're taking off masks we're going
indoors and as the temperature gets
colder we're seeing cases rise pretty
dramatically in the country 127 000
cases in the u.s yesterday so certainly
getting together for the holidays is
something we all enjoy and have to do
and we will do but we have to do it
safely which means as much as possible
get the kids vaccinated
do testing home antigen testing before a
gathering if people are at high risk or
if people aren't vaccinated i think it's
going to be mandated or should be
mandated across the country and we can
all do it and we should do it be safe
for the holidays
and dr aegis you talk about kids we know
that pfizer two weeks ago got the fda
approval for their vaccine for ages five
to 11. now we're waiting for moderna
what's the latest with that why do you
think it's it's taking so long
well pfizer did their trials alone
moderna is doing it but in a different
way and what they've seen is a little
bit more of the heart infection in
children and so the fda said we need
some more data we have to review it
probably through january so it's going
to take a while before we have modernity
for the lower age groups that being said
the pfizer vaccine is remarkably safe
and it works and
obviously we have it down to five
through eleven the hope is by the end of
the year we have it for six months for
age four and we can really vaccinate
hopefully most of the country
doctor the surgeon general said this
week that he thinks kovid will
eventually hopefully get to a place
where it's somewhere between
the cold and the flu
how long does that take and what does
that mean
so you know with the flu we're certainly
less worried than kova because we have a
pill we have tamiflu if you're exposed
or you have mild symptoms you take it
and you get better well there are two
such pills for kova 19 that hopefully
will remove will get emergency youth
authorization from the fda in the next
month or so and that's going to be a
game changer because we can prevent
hospitalization give people a pill and
they go home and take it that being said
you know we hope it's not something that
is always around and unless we finish
the vaccination program in the united
states it certainly will be we have to
get our vaccine numbers believe it or
not with delta it looks like to the mid
90 percent range
okay dr aegis thank you very much as
always